Hành phố Chí Minh đang đầy mạnh dẻ ngân vốn đầu tư công nhằm thuộc đầy các sự an hạt tự giá thông quan trọc,
tạo động lực cho phát triển kinh tế, xa hội.
Năm 20 hủ trăm 20 lâm, bán quan lý sự an đầu tư xe dựng công chình giá thông bình dương,
thành phố Chí Minh được xa hơn 20, 20 xa năm nay tìa đồng.
Tập trung cho các sự an, cào tốt và đường vành đại như vành đai ba, vành đai bún và cào tốt thịt phố Chí Minh,
thu dầu một, trân thành.
Nguồn không vật liệu sẽ được bộ xung tự các mỏ cá và đã tại đồng tháp, vĩnh lòng, đồng này và bình dương.
Bên cảnh đó, bắt ra thông thành phố Chí Minh được xa hơn 20, 20, 20,
tì đồng để chình hai các sự an, bởi giống quốc lộ, chục bác, năm và các tiến cửa ngó.
Tình phố đang lỗ lực thảo gỡ vượt mắt về thu tục, mặt bằng, vật liệu,
đồng thời đầy mạnh thi công bà cá, bốn kịp, phần đầu dả ngân đặt 1 trong phần chăm kế vạc trong năm 2020.